well a great restaurant is a restaurant
that fires on all cylinders it's one
that you feel comfortable and privileged
and even a little bit pampered to sit in
you know pampered by the way everything
around you looks pampered by the way the
servers are dealing with you it's a
restaurant that has terrific service but
that means service that is it is
calibrated well to the environment that
is as and no more stilted than the
environment calls for or as and no more
informal than the environment calls for
that is certainly attentive but without
being unduly intrusive and obsequious so
then there's that whole element and then
you know first and foremost a restaurant
that gives you food you want to eat food
that is distinguished in its genre food
that makes sense again in terms of the
menus entirety in terms of the
environment in terms of the service so
it's a restaurant that kind of knows
what it is fires on all cylinders and
sends you out the door three hours later
were two hours later or it could be 90
minutes later if it's a momofuku ssam
bar that sends you at the door feeling
utterly content and feeling like it's
promises were kept
a gram you can have just you know one
perfect bhutan blanc sausage and that
can be is that a dish well sure you know
it's the same it again boils down to
something that does exactly what it
means to do and that delivers exactly
what it promises in its written
description and in its kind of visual
form as you look at it
well in technical ways it does I mean in
terms of I can't there are not many
nights where I can just go to whatever
restaurant I want to because I have a
schedule to keep and a list of new
restaurants to try and a list of
restaurants that are going to be
reviewed that I have to visit you know a
second and third or you know sometimes
for three and fifth time so in that
sense yeah I just I just don't eat like
a normal person I don't I don't just
kind of in the morning or at 4pm say
what do I feel like for dinner tonight I
mean I sometimes know four weeks in
advance exactly where I'm going to be on
februari 28th does it get in the way of
just eating in terms of sitting there
and just enjoying a piece of food
without thinking about it to death no no
I mean it eating is such a primal
visceral thing that I think you'd have
to get very very jaded not to be able to
just bite into a juicy hamburger you
know and just kind of hum all over
without wondering exactly what
composition of ground beef is in there
you know
the Italian food in New York is
extremely good it is it's different in a
lot of ways if you if you go to most
most good Italian restaurants in Rome or
in most parts of Italy the approaches is
much simpler than it is here one of the
things that invariably happens when
you're a restaurant serving an ethnic
cuisine in a city where rents are as
high as New York and where ambitions are
as large and and vanity as keen as it is
in New York is you start fussing with
the food a lot and so I think inevitably
and predictably a lot of the finest and
most ambitious Italian restaurants here
do a much more you know articulated
embellished elaborate version of Italian
cooking than some of your best
restaurants in Rome do Rome being
actually a good example but that's true
of other areas of Italy as well taking
that out of the equation and taking out
of the equation the fact that I don't
think we have the same we still even in
this day and age don't have quite the
same kind of farm to table or short a
table systems in places they do in
certain European countries including
Italy beyond all that the Italian food
here's is I think quite quite good
I can't do that either again too many of
them there's just too many I mean there
are a lot of very good ones I mean if
you're if you're if you're if you're in
a kind of laid back don't want a lot of
fuss but want something that feels warm
and homey mood there are a lot of
options including al de la out in park
slope of Brooklyn's folia on the Upper
East Side but everything has an asterisk
I mean you talk about those two places
both of which I gave two stars to and
aldi law doesn't take reservations and
Foley is almost impossible to get a
reservation between six and nine p.m. so
you know when you start dealing with
like short lists everything kind of as
an asterisk or qualification if you're
talking about very fancy Italian or not
even very fancy but kind of a price
point above those places there are
wonderful options including you know
babo and a voce and and for a very
Frenchified kind of Kwazii Italian
Fiamma down in Tribeca Alto on the east
side I mean there are a lot of options
and it's hard to single anyone out as
the perfect one